Hausa going back but it's brown in fat
so you bro suggests me a lot of games
learned anything from minecraft to call
of duty to today which you suggested
muscle March now some people would argue
and say this looks game but if you look
closely there's actually a polar bear
that look it's right there that face
seriously nail it
yeah mmm all right let's see Russell
marsh I could either be Tony Tony is
from USA and okay and I the Bob always
cool a baby good and my favorite of
course
Pedrosa from Spain I love her is from
Norway cheerful how do you do that date
Brenda is from the UK and she's a happy
she'll later I don't know what makes me
more comfortable Brenda as a man or
Brenda as a woman even way it's really
disturbing let's go with Brenda because
she's from the UK and I meet UK right
now let's do space what what are they do
it oh now face the penguin what what the
penguins and chickens are outraged go
through the wall be the same pose okay
so this is I play
nice look at that ass look at that nice
ass it's so distracting oh there we go
alright so you make the same pose as the
wall or whatever by by flexing oh god I
clearly don't even know how to do it
mmm oh we're running in the air that
should make sense
while we are in space so I guess it's
okay where we stopping oh no then write
it now I'll come back for your last leg
around there for a home a character or
whatever is going on oh no it's a big
role so oh god damnit Rajasa you're my
first love I still really enjoy playing
this game it's so [ __ ] weird plus you
get to see butts shaking so what else
you need honestly and you get to be
fabulous
what I totally hit it oh yeah yeah I'm
gonna get I'm gonna get you're gonna tee
that's right tuck it down tuck it down
come here my little lovelies oh oh yeah
oh what a lahar this polar bear bear
whatever who cares how the polar bear is
from Norway because everyone knows
anyone from Scandinavia is a polar bear
I feel like Brenda is a little too
offensive for my taste so let's just go
with Ross like who invited Ross anyway
you know what we should have our bearing
our muscle team he started with muscular
it's his fat like anyone from
Scandinavia
oh yes fabulous though you got a handy
jerk okay
[ __ ] oh now Brandon oh he's like oh yeah
I'm gonna getcha oh yeah I'm gonna hit I
hit my Japanese humor is sister weirdest
[ __ ] ever oh I should really like the
music this song is pretty sweet I'm a
beer
I'm here I'm up here oh how about that
ass jiggling so sexy come on it's pretty
hot don't give me that look you have no
taste in polar bears what how are they
still okay okay oh no not at all sir
for Joe I love you so fabulous oh we're
going off in hyperspace manly manly
games you have to look for I think the
story of this game is a lot more
inspiring than beyond two souls come on
gotta get you getting [ __ ] get your
ass lava its face oh that's not a good
idea
Oh Oh God come on it's on it's on like
Donkey Kong I mean it sounds like
barabar never gonna
it's so fast this game is faster than
sanic I'm gonna get you I got you
Oh doesn't matter what pulls your bag oh
god I got it so fast what is happening
I'm coming for you I'm coming for you
that's what this game has bad influence
on me
Oh God who's that guy what is he doing
not again mecha muscle Mac muscle that
outfit no seriously that ass oh wow
I'm pretty sure the bunt doesn't go in
the front but what do I know but let's
go home fabulous to the beer look
seriously look at it he's nailing gosh
this is me giving [ __ ] no one cares
about a ride into a god damn it [ __ ]
pants it's the learning the difficult
care in this game is just absolutely
crazy oh god oh god
oh it's Sarge up some reason but it gets
on forgiveness what they doing out in
space
get out of here bread that you'll never
be as fabulous as me oh oh oh are you
serious how hello-o
Oh my name is on listening to this I
gotta have it follow me
winning jackpot got a step we're gonna
make this [ __ ] okay and do it oh I'm a
noob good thing oh hey hey got it so
focus oh god oh god I got I got I got it
oh not done that by back sent him in the
real name
Oh God later Brenda oh I'll do it for
your brother - seriously what the [ __ ]
how do you do that how I can't even if I
tried
oh [ __ ] I think this game is the reason
for twerking I think it was released in
like two years ago oh oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god come
on god I hate you just make a post do Oh
yeah Vanessa perfect [ __ ] perfect
[ __ ] I'm damn favorite and you know
it Oh God it tricks you it wrecks you
I wasn't even close okay I'm right here
you haven't met that dude ah oh oh
snuh snuh just hey what don't fake poses
come on baby
there's a cognac mmm oh I know that pose
uh-huh I hit my hand in the Sheridan
hurts a lot but I'm dealing with it
oh wow this game is so easy really way
too easy I mean whatever what do I get
muscle prince I'll take that [ __ ] so
cool why thank you
strange man Thank You ppreciate it what
do you think penguins come back for
another no no thank you penguins no
thank you
alright that was muscles March thank you
boys for suggesting these [ __ ] [ __ ]
up games that I would never have found
otherwise
I hope you boys enjoyed watching and
there I got a good exercise SAS press
love you
you